now on this story we're covering all
morning let's go back to Gale in McAllen
Texas near the us-mexico border Gail oh
thank you John
here at the detention center right
behind me hundreds of people are
awaiting federal prosecution after being
charged with crossing the border
illegally there are many families here
in addition to children separated from
their mothers and fathers some parents
may go to jail or be deported others
could be released to face hearings in
civil immigration courts across the unit
United States for those who are released
though many go to shelters for help
trying to figure out their next move
every day at the McAllen Texas bus
station dozens of migrant families
released from detention are dropped off
on the curb many have just been reunited
after spending days apart from each
other not knowing where to go
volunteers escort the group three blocks
to the Catholic Charities respite center
children are provided with clean clothes
toys and entertainment a welcome
distraction while parents get help on
how to reach destinations like Los
Angeles and New York most families speak
little English and are exhausted sister
Norma Pimentel is the center's executive
director these people have heard a lot
but they're told that they're breaking
the law and there are consequences for
that they're entering the country asking
for protection how can that be breaking
the law they're not running away they're
simply saying I need your help
my life is in danger Christina Melgar
traveled from El Salvador with her 16
year old daughter and ten year old son
she says they were separated for six
days after being arrested at the border
when you came to the border did you
think that you could be separated from
your children
what happened did you all feel safe I
couldn't see them then so I was with
this dumbest thing you asked me ago I
was scared you were scared Melgar says
she left El Salvador for fear they would
be killed if her daughter refused to
join a gang children Martius avala also
traveled from El Salvador with his ten
year old son if you knew you could be
separated why would you take that risk
I'm Dennis how do you know it was a big
welcome sign when you first walk in but
there are a lot of people in the country
that don't welcome them what do you say
to those people they see that child that
I have seen when those Charles are
looking at me with those fool it faces
full of tears ask you me help me how can
you not help that child